[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mes petits amis
bon ouah pas trop mais oui nounours ils
ont été très sages
je vais le raconter la suite des
aventures du petit cornichons attendu
patron je descends leur montrer le livre
le seul nos propres propos notre petit
ami se trouve à présent chez le gros
bûcheron qui l'a recueilli il qui
s'occupe de lui
en attendant qu'il retrouve ses parents
l'histoire oui raconte un an vous pas
trop pardon monsieur vous n'avez pas vu
notre petit garçon cornichons demande le
papa de cornichons au vieux vitrier au
oui il était bien gentil ce petit il m'a
aidé à porter mes vitres et où est il
vous le savez me fois non
une partie moi j will annonce va ainsi y
lit avec les bûcherons dans la forêt de
petit coûte la suite le papa et la maman
de cornichons ainsi que dada qui tire la
roulotte sont arrivés dans la grande
ville et il continue à chercher partout
leur petit garçon le pot ce qu'il doive
se trouve pardon madame vous n'avez pas
vu mon fils cornichons demande la maman
à une grande dame aigre qui porte un
chignon maigre et pointue sur la tête à
la salle où les modèles 1 m à chalon du
colo quoi en échange quand les champs ah
oui il a réparé mais les nerfs oui il à
ramoner la cheminée peut pas trop mal ma
foi et puis les parties va par là mais
voilà qu'un agent de police s'approchent
de la roulotte pas il manquait plus que
ça au long sur que lui et plus vite que
ça
vous voyez bien que dans cette ville il
n'y a pas de place pour une roulotte en
avant ses revenus
mais oui alors dada le papa et la maman
de cornichons quitte tout triste cette
grande ville dans laquelle ils n'ont pas
trouvé leur fils et ils s'en vont à sa
recherche dans la grande forêt ce
qu'alain ils ont retrouvé à oui hélas
non cette forêt si grande que corniche
on n'entend pas la jolie musique que son
papa joue pour lui à la guitare
et notre petit garçon s'endort bien au
chaud dans la cabane de bois du gentil
bussereau en pensant à sa maman à son
papa il ya son ami dada et la peau leur
malheureux mais il y retrouvera chez
part a dit nous ne le serons au bout vu
allons les offrants l'histoire est finie
[Musique]
ce qu'ils sont et non
les jolis paniers grenelle 2
bonne nuit les petits la jette à l heure
à 2
à demain bonne nuit petit nicolas bonne
nuit petite impro neil bonne nuit tous
les enfants allez vite vous coucher ben
auparavant n'oubliez pas te faire votre
toilette et de bien vous l'a vu le don
est fait de beaux rêves
à demain bolden
[Musique]